Emmie pees on the civil liberties
committee proposed an overhaul this week
of the so-called Dublin rules on asylum
which say the country refugee arrives in
is the country tasked with their asylum
request they want a central system for
requests including member state quotas
it passed by 44 votes to 11 it is
natural that the Dublin regulation has
very negative connotations because what
is places is a disproportionate burden
on member states that had that are at
the periphery as an EU summit on
migration began in Brussels on first aid
martin short's president of the
parliament met with King Abdullah the
second of Jordan and the Cypriot
president nicos Anastasiades meanwhile
emmy peas harnessed social media to
reach out to citizens on the crisis
French MEP Joe our tree and civilian led
a 45-minute live facebook chat but after
reported lively challenging and
connecting exchanges European Commission
has gun controls in its sights demanding
stricter controls over museums and
collectors and on buying firearms online
the idea is to limit terrorists ability
to rebuild + Shift weapons across
borders a public hearing held by the
internal market committee leading
experts were wary mep s want a better
balance between the fight against
terrorism and the rights of those with a
legitimate case to hold firearms
big-hitting multinationals ikea
McDonald's Google and Apple we're called
by the special committee on tax rulings
for their stance on new proposals on
corporate tax designed to close
loopholes and arrangements that allow
companies to slash their tax liabilities
scarcely surprising that their
representatives went keen on several key
elements like country-by-country
reporting of profits taxes and subsidies
and making them public cool and Apple
try to give a wrong and impression about
their tax behavior
on Wednesday em EPS on the employment
committee supported calls for a rewrite
of legislation on parental leave that
goes back to nineteen ninety-six but
they consider how to sync with today's
economic and social climate this is a
parliamentary initiative which the
Commission doesn't have to follow but
it's supported by several major Union
and social organizations